では よろしくお願いします
はい これから今日のお話に入ります
こういうテーマで あの
意志と動機ですね まあ左遷
左遷しないためということで
まあ人間にとっては一般的にある問題でね
何かやろうとしてもまあ途中で嫌になっちゃうんでしょうしね
なかなか途中で嫌にならないということっていうのはほとんどないんです
まあいろいろ原因はありますけど
まあまあ それなんか全部今日は取り扱うしないことにしまして
ほんの一部だけ説明します
で 今日はまあ このお釈迦様のたったこの一行の言葉に中心にしてお話します
わあやめてえわ プリソヤーはアッタッサニッパダという大変な有名な言葉で
意味は人は目的に達するまで努力するものですと
で 今日の話はそれだけなんです
わあやめてよ プリソヤーアッタッサニッパダ
何か努力するならば 結果出すまでやるもんだよと
ということは 当たり前のことのように聞こえますね
ブッダの言葉っていうのは
大体どちらでも なんだ当たり前じゃないかと思えるんですけど
でも当たり前じゃないんですよ
人間に発見できないことを言ってるんです
今まで発見できなかったことを言ってるんです
それが当たり前のことを語れるのは
お釈迦様はもう修学者だからなんです
もう何も欠点ないんだからなんです
で こちらで言うのは精進しなさいと
もうどうしようもないんだよと
他選択ないんだよと だから挫折なんかっていうのは成り立じゃないんです
だから人間であるならば
生命であるならば もう選択はないんです
もう精進するしかないんです
そういうことなんです
だから これはまあ 存在って何でしょうか？生きるということは何でしょうか？という同じ質問の答えなんです
それに努力する世界なんです
それはサンユットニカーヤに出てきます
では 中身に入ります まあまず
まあ一応当たり前のこと聞こえますけどね
結果が出るまで頑張るのは当たり前だと
しかし 我々は諦めるんですね
これはなぜでしょうかと
1番目は本来の怠けに負けるんですね
生命に本来怠けというものがあります
それに負けるんです  2番目は目的は見えるが
過程は見えないという問題がありますね
3番目は性格的に優柔不断ですよ
4番目は目的は曖昧 清らかではない
曖昧な清らかでない目的の場合は
なんか途中で諦める羽目になるんです
5番目は心の汚れにより柔軟性はない
人間は柔軟性がないんですね
かなり頑固ですね 硬いんです
だから折れちゃいます
6番目は無知が自分を支配するんですね
我々は無知に聞いて行動しています
理性に知恵に話を聞かないんです
無知が何か言ったら 自分の心のことですけど
すぐそれに従います そういう大体 6つぐらいのポイントを扱ってはみます
はい それではこの一つ一つ詳しく説明していきます
1番目 本来の怠けという
生命といえば怠け者なんです
ごまかしはできませんよ
いい 私は違いますよと
これはありえないんです
生き物なら怠け者に決まってます
だから生命の本能は怠けることです
本当に我々の本能から聞いてみると
本能っていうのは怠けることなんです
どんな努力する人でも怠け本能でやってるんです
いつか怠けたいと それではね
生きていられないので
もういやいやで踏ん張るんですよ
怠けたいんだけど 怠けては生きていられないんですね
すぐ死んでしまうんですよ
怠けたいんだけど 怠けると死んでしまうんだから
もういやいやでみんな踏ん張ってます
そういうことだから 挫折するということは当たり前の現象になるんです
決して気分よく明るくやっているわけじゃないんです
何やっても我々は嫌で嫌でやっているんです
できればやめたいと これできないからやっているという生命なんです
それで怠けるために努力するので
必ずこの矛盾に遭遇するんですよ
これはよく勉強した方がいいんですよ
世の中にみんななんで努力するのかというと
怠けるために努力するんです
科学研究も開発も すべて怠けるためなんですね
より楽な人生のためにやっているんです
だから より楽な人生のためにむちゃくちゃ苦労するということは矛盾でしょうに
だからこの世の中からは矛盾というのはもう立ちされません
矛盾でできているんです
なんでそんな苦労して
徹夜までして仕事をしているのかというと
これ怠けるためなんです
楽をするためなんですよ
では このいろいろえーと
何でしたっけ？修行する人々はどうでしょうかと
あれも結局これで超能力で身について
まあ楽になるでしょう
結局は怠けるためにやっているんです
で いろいろ経典がありましてね
ものすごい厳密な哲学的なセクションもありましたけど
今日はちょっとそれは紹介しないことにしましたけど
この怠けの問題はね そういうわけで
我々は何をしても何か矛盾にぶつかるんですよ
子供でも勉強しなさいと言っちゃうと
まあいやいやで始まりますけど
それでもやっている途中で真剣真面目に勉強している途中で
また矛盾にぶつかる こんなことやったって何か意味があるのかとかね
きめ細かい数学やあれこれで
こんなことはいつどこで何のために使うのか
どっちでも使う場がないんだからね
だから矛盾にぶつかるんですよ
まあ例えばまあよく言うこと
まあ死んじゃったら全部終わりでしょうと
それもこの矛盾なんですね
いろんなことをやったって
もう死んじゃえば全部終わりだから
もういいからやめちゃえばいいんじゃないかという気分になるんです
余計なことをしないで
ということで いつでも怠けというものは我々の心の中で
本来ついていて 私たちはまあかなり攻撃しているんです
楽をすることではなく
努力することを楽しみに生き甲斐にしないと解決できない
それで解決方法はこれなんです
楽をするためにあれこれと努力するんじゃないんです
ちょっと理性で見ると
無知で聞かないで まあいっぱい今苦労して勉強して
もうこれから大変人生は楽になりますよということは
これは無知なんですね
よく勉強すれば まあものすごい収入の高い給料の高い仕事で見つかるでしょうとかね
そうすると楽々だよ そんなのありえません
苦労して勉強した人は
それなりの給料が高い仕事には就きますけど
仕事はものすごい難しいんです
楽じゃないんだよ 責任が多くて
大変ですよ だから我々言っているのは
このちょこっと苦労すれば楽になるぞというのは
これは真っ赤な嘘なんです
嘘にも嘘に求めて生きてるんだから
矛盾に出会います それで解決方法っていうのは
今苦労したらこれから楽になるんだよではなくて
この努力すること 何かに挑戦することで怠けがなくなるんですよ
怠けも本当に苦しいんですよ
命に関わるんですね だからこの努力することが
まあこれは楽しいと それであなたに何かがなるか
いや それは考えてないんだと
ただ努力していくんだけど
そうすると瞬間瞬間の努力は楽しみになるんです
努力が楽しみになるんですけど
努力の結果 大変な楽しみが待ち構えているぞと言ったら
これが嘘なんです そういう
そういうことで努力すること自体生きがいにしておけば
全然矛盾にぶつからないんです
このいろんなもう大事な発見している科学者たちは
一つ発見する場合はむちゃくちゃ失敗しているんです
それですごくお金がなくなったり
研究費はね 時々もう 1年
2年 もう時々 3年 5年かけてずっともう積み重ねてきた研究が
ちょっとしたことで全部パーになったりとか
あるいはその理屈は全部ダメっていう風になったりしますよ
それでそういう人々は
はぁ 結果がないんだ もう嫌やと挫折するかと
そうじゃないんです そういう人々は
あの苦労して馬鹿げた研究することが楽しんでるんですね
そこでたまたま良い結果が出たりする
だから挫折しない この世の中で挫折しないで何か結果出している人々っていうのは
大体その努力すること自体を楽しんでいるんですね
だから この我々が本来持っている怠けに対して
それしか答えがないと思います
次にいきます では 見える目的と見えない過程ということで
我々にはすごい目的はいっぱいありますね
人生には こうなりたい
ああなりたいという目的はいっぱいあるんだけど
その目的にどのように達するのかという
これはあんまり気にしないんですね
だから目的も大事かもしれませんだけど
その目的に達する目的を実現する過程
方法 プロセスも 大事であるし
どちらかというとプロセスの方が大事なんです
例えば過程を楽しむならば
精進することを楽しむならば
プロセスが自体が楽しい
大事ですよ 目的は本当はどうでもいいんです
で 過程無視すると途中で終わるか
夢で終わるかなんですよ
夢があって目的があって
あまりどのようにすればとわからなくて
頑張っても途中でやめる羽目になるんですね
あるいは方法がないと
ただ頭だけで妄想だけで終わっちゃうんですね
よく考えてほしいのは
目的には瞬間に達するんですよ
しかし そのプロセス プロセスには何年もかかります
例えばオリンピックで金メダルを取ることが目的だとすると
あんなのは瞬間の出来事でしょ
たった瞬間です はい この人かって勝ちましたと
1になりました 走り競技だったら
あのリボンに胸がつける瞬間で目的に達しているんです
つけた瞬間にリボンが落ちますからね
だから目的っていうのは瞬間の出来事
しかし そこまでの過程
どれぐらいかかってますかね
小さい時から走って走って走って
また選ばれたところで国の代表として
それからまた厳しい訓練を受けて受けて
毎日毎日 すべて他のことを全部やめて
遊ぶことも 友達の関係も全部やめちゃって
同じ歳の人々と話を話したり喋ったり
それも全くできない そういう風な
この長い時間の過程があるんだから
それ苦しいんだったら人生台無しでしょうね
例えばもう 7  8年オリンピックに出るために訓練したとすれば
その訓練自体がもう最悪苦しいんだと
苦しかったと言っちゃうと
その人には苦しみしかないでしょうね
あのほんのわずかな瞬間の楽しみしかないんだよと思うと
妄想で観念で生きている羽目になっちゃうんですね
だから過程が楽しかったというと
あんなメダルなんかはどうでもいいってことになるんです
もらったってもどこかに置いておくんです
だからその人々は挫折はしませんね
目的より過程に時間がかかります
そういうことだから 知識人は常に今の行為を気にして
これでこの行為で自分の目的に達するのかと常にチェックを入れるんですよ
無知ではなくて 知識人なら
理性の人なら目的は置いておいて
今やっていることで自分がその目的に達するのかと
いつでも今をチェックするんですね
だから勉強の本を置いておいて
漫画の本を見ているならば
頭のいい子だったらこれで合格するんでしょうかと
自分に聞いてみれば 漫画を見ても合格をするはずはないんだからね
それを置いておいて また勉強する
その時 これではどうでしょう
あ これだったらなんとかうまくいけそうと
そうすると そちらで喜びが生まれてくるんですね
3番目 優柔不断ということ
何で優柔不断かというと
この無知 欲 そういう感情で気持ちは定まらないんですね
何か決めることはできないんですね
あれも欲しいんだけど
これも欲しいんだけど
しかしあれは嫌で これというふうな感じで心がもう動くんですね
定まらないんです  これかなり大きな問題なんですね
エネルギーは出てこない
例えば自分が何か目的を決めたら
まあでもこれって大変だよとわかっても
いや 私はやっぱり大変なことがあることはわかりますけど
まあこれにしますと 優柔不断だと
大変ですかね ではやめようかな
どうかな もっと楽なものないかなとかね
それであります 楽なこの目的
でもそれは大した目的
そうですね それはあんまり大した目的じゃないしね
まあと で 優柔不断でしょうね
だったら大した大事な目的にしない
でもやっぱりそれ苦しいでしょうとかね
競争は激しいでしょうとかね
そういう風にいろいろ
問題が起きるんで それ欲と無知ですね
あるいは目の前の楽しみに惹かれるんですね
設計して人生をやるんじゃなくて
自分の目の前である楽しみに惹かれて
人生はダメになるんですね
まあこれ大変大きな問題で
ほとんどの人々は人生失敗するのは目の前のことで
まあ楽しみを追おうとしているんだからなんです
そういう優柔不断な人っていうのは
何を決めても簡単に諦めてしまうんです
簡単にやめてしまうんです
それから何かやっている時でも
誰かにいとも簡単に誘惑してやめさせることはできます
そういうこと それで優柔不断な人にはもうやる気も精進もできない
決して気持ちは定めてないんだから
やる気は出てこないんです
優柔不断であっても やってみればいいんではないかと言ったっても
やってみればということできないんですよ
やること自体できない
そのエネルギーがないんです
これって性格なんです
優柔不断ということは
だからまあ これがもうとにかく直さないと力が出てこないんです
だから成功する見込みは全くないし
で 他人に依存するんですね
よくもう他人がなければ
人がなければという性格があるっていうのは
これ優柔不断ということなんですね
みんなやるならばやるとかね
人気者タレントがやっているならばやるとかね
では情けない人生なんですよ
優柔不断ということははっきりしています
自分で決めてやらなくちゃいけないんです
やることは みんなやってるんだから
流行りだからやるということは
明らかに自分が情けない
優柔不断の気持ち定まらない
依存型の人間であるということなんです
だからそういう人々は成功した人生は期待しない方がいいんです
4番目 目的は曖昧で清らかではないと
曖昧な目的だったら方法論はないでしょう
この曖昧っていうのは
自分の目的は有意義かそうでないかということをはっきりしないんですね
まあ何かやるぞと決めたら
これは本当に有意義でしょう
あるいはこれは無意味でしょうか
と これははっきり区別した方がいいんです
2つに分けた方がいいんです
それを分けないで まあいいんじゃないんでしょうか
もしかするといいことになるんじゃないかと
このいいことになるんじゃないかということは
もう曖昧ということなんですね
いえ これがすればいいことになるんだよと
はっきりしないと もしかするといいことになるかもしれませんとか
そういう状態ではね だからこの目的は曖昧か否かということは
決める方法っていうのは
この有意義でしょうかと
たったそれだけなんです
それで汚れた目的だったら
いくら頑張ってもうまくいかない可能性っていうのはほとんど多いんです
それはどういうことでしょうかね
書いてますかね 書いてます
汚れた目的の場合 良い側面より悪い側面の方が大きいんです
まあ例で考えれば まあ金持ちになりたいんだから銀行強盗すると
だからその場合はもう銀行強盗が目的になるんですね
金持ちになりたいっていうことも一緒ですからね
良い目的はすぐ存じて大金は手に入ります
良い側面は しかし 大金手に入る良いところ以外
悪いところっていうのはものすごいたくさんあるんですね
だからうまくいくはずがないんです
途中で逮捕されたりする可能性はいくらでもあります
あるいはちょっと失敗してそこで殺される可能性もあります
うまくいかない悪い目的の場合は
もう社会は攻撃してこれをやらせないんですよ
銀行強盗は大胆な例ですけど
我々は色々汚れた目的で行動はしていますけど
社会はそれはやらせないんですね
いろいろ非難したり 罰を与えたり
いろんなことをしますから
うまくいかないんです
自分が目的に達する前に不幸になったり
社会から非難を受けたりはする
ですから 目的が汚れているならば
もうどうしようもないんですね
挫折する羽目になるんです
はい そういうことで 5番目に行きます
心の汚れより柔軟性はなくなること
能力といえば限りなくあるんです
心っていうのはすごい不可思議な
必ず不可思議なものなんですよ
すべて物質的な世界さえも支配できるんです
ものすごいエネルギーがあるんです
心に何ができるのかではなくて
心に何ができないのかっていうことなんです
それぐらいの能力があるんです
しかし 我々の能力にはリミットがあるようですね
しかし 私たちは まあやっぱり自分にはそんな能力はないんだと
リミットがあると思っているんです
まあ頑張ってみてもね
そんなに成長するはずもないしね
だから能力にはリミットがあると俗世間ではよく思っています
しかし 能力っていうのは無限大でリミットがないんです
お釈迦様はたった心だけの力で
この宇宙の 現れ方 なくなり方をずっと目の前で見ているように見たんだから
経験したんだから これ一回だけじゃないでしょうね
ビッグバンで現れたりして
またビッグカンチになって消えたりするし
それを光年こうだと 1 光と数字まで入れちゃったりして
これはまあ ここから私は 40個過去を遡って見たところでとか語るんです
何のこともなく 随分淡々と
嘘を言っているわけじゃないでしょうね
ある 別な宗教の行者がこの行為について質問して
天国に行くためにはどういうことをするべきか
あれこれと聞いたところで
あの この漁業者たちの人々がね
どうでしょうかね 死後天国に行きますかと聞いちゃうと
お釈迦様はこれから 20年
20  20個を遡ってみると
二人が天国に生まれたことがありますと
20個なんですよ すごい時間
1個っていうのはビッグバンからビッグバンまででしょ
これ 20 見たところで
二人ぐらい天国に生まれたことがあります
その人々も行為に結果があるんだということを信じていたんだと
あの いわゆる形而上学的な哲学では宗教ではなくて
具体的で 行為には結果がありますよと
だから天国に生まれたんだ
大変なことですよ その質問した人はすごく驚きましたけどね
なんて無駄なことを我々やっているのかと
だから今 現代 我々には
なんだこの話はと思うかもしれません
だけど お釈迦様は心には無限の力があるんだよということはもう実証しているんです
あの広いインドで 至る所で弟子たちが修行していたんだから
1箇所で集めてもらうことはできなかったでしょうに
でもみんなにちゃんと話してるんです
みんなにちゃんと個人個人指導をしているんです
しながら お釈迦様は自分の人間としてのプログラム
スケジュール それなりに順番で歩いてはいるんです
順番で歩いているんだからといって
遠いところにいる人に会うことできないとか
それはないんです どうやってそれするんでしょうかね
それは心の力なんですよ
だからお釈迦様がもう来るしょうがない
遠いところにいるお坊さんでも
私にはお釈迦様はこういうふうに言われましたと
はっきりと知っているんです
その人の前にちゃんと現れて
もう話を聞いて どういうことでしょうか
じゃあこうこうしなさいとかね
ちゃんと言って それからもう帰ると帰りますけど
本当はその普通には人間に理解できないことなんですね
そういうことで 心には無限の力があるんだということは
だからお釈迦様っていうのはものすごい心が柔軟性でしたからね
しかし 私たちにはすごいリミットがあるんですね
自害意識で心を固めるので柔軟性がなくなる
一番我々は超能力のことを置いておいて
人間としてなんで能力ないのかというと
この自害意識が この幻覚がすっと自分を固めちゃうんですね
自害意識があまりにも強すぎになっちゃうと
引きこもりになっちゃうんです
柔軟性が必要なんです
このいじめで自殺する場合でも
自害意識が強すぎなんですね
いじめる側も もうすごい最悪ですよ
自害意識っていうのは
自分という気分なく行動すると
何かなく何でもできるようになるんですよ
私 私 自分 自分という考え方入れば入るほどもう動かなくなっちゃうんです
それで成長することはできなくなるんですよ
それでこの自害意識が
これもちょっと覚えた方がいいんですね
目的に達するための頑固は強い意志ですが
頑固は成長しないんですね
自害意識が強い人に 我々は普通頑固と言うんでしょ
人の話は聞かないし なかなかめげないし
滑らかじゃないし これ違うぞと言ったっても認めないって頑固と言うでしょうね
それが悪い頑固で 目的に達するための誘惑に負けないで
しっかりと努力することが頑固ということじゃないんです
それは良い頑固なんです
優柔不断がないということで
だから頑固と言っても
これは俗世間の言葉で仏教の単語じゃないんだからね
俗世間の頑固と言っても 2種類あるということで覚えてください
我々は正しい頑固でならなきゃ優柔不断なんです
間違った頑固だったらもう何もできなくて
そのまま体が動かなくなっちゃって硬くなって
もう人生はダメになるんです
で これはちょっとテーマがすごく広いんですよ
心は硬くなるっていうことは
これはもうすごい ちょっと時間をかけて説明する羽目になります
俗世間の教育なども心を硬くするんですよ
我々は教育を受けますね
そうすると 柔軟性な心がどんどん新しい概念入って入って入って
硬く硬く硬くなっていくんですよ
教育受けたならないという話じゃないんです
教育にはそういう問題があるんです
何か訓練する 何かもう何でも同じことでね
何かを学ぶ 専門知識を得るということは
ある分野の概念で心を固めて
他に対して柔軟性を失うことです
特に専門世界 プロの世界というのはそういうことなんです
一つはできるんだけど
他できなくなるんです
全くも能力も何もなくなっちゃうんです
馬鹿になるんです 自分の専門以外はもう全く無知で
馬鹿でも教えたくてもできないということになってしまうんです
というわけで 教育はいいことかもしれませんだけど
教育によっても自我をしっかり固定するんです
俗世間の教育だからね
それにも解決策はありますよ
今日は言わないんですけど
ですから 一人に一つ二つのことしか学べ学べないんです
たくさんのことを学べるはずですけど
例えば外国語にしても
時たまいますね もう 12か国語をものすごいペラペラ喋られるとかね
どういう脳細胞を持ってるか
なんかすごい不思議でしょ
何のことなく入れ替えたりすることはできますよ
例えばドイツ語とフランス語を同時に喋れと言っちゃうと
もうおかしくなると思いますよ
思考パターンものすごい違いますよ
ドイツ語で喋る場合は
考え方はあるパターンがあります
物事をしっかり先に決めておかなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからドイツ人的には優柔不断はなりません
優柔不断ではドイツ語は勉強できないんです
何か言おうと思ったら
何言いたいかとはっきり先に決めておかないと
なぜならば 動詞が確実に二番目に来なくちゃいけないんです
それから動詞は長いんだったら
残りは全部最後に言わなくちゃいけないんです
フランス語っていうのはそうじゃなくて
しゃべり出してつなげてつなげてつなげていけばいいんです
だから曖昧でいいんです
しかし 一人の人がその二つのプロになると
結構才能が必要ですよ
まだイタリア語とかね
また違うでしょうし これにあの
もう一つ あれは何でしたっけ？アメリカで使う言語は
あの 何でしたっけ？英語じゃなくて
英語よりも使ってる 何でしたっけ？スペイン語ですね
スペイン語をしゃべる人の方が多いんです
アメリカでは スペイン語の使い方はまた違いますからね
それにそれでアジアの言語をしゃべるようになっちゃうと
それでタイ語になってくると
すごいイントネーションが絡んでくるし
タイ語を学んで中国語を学ぼうと思っちゃうと
イントネーションの使い方また違うんです
しかし できる人がいますよ
だから誰かにできるということは
誰にでも論理的にできるはずなんです
どうって何でも人間作ったもんだから
部長でも人間作ったもんだから
なんでできないんですかね
できないってことは 我々の心は固めているんだからなんです
日本の英語の教育の場合は
まあまあ あまり知らないんだけど
まあ一般的にちょこちょこっと見たとこの私の偏見的な判断なんですけど
よく気をつけてるポイントがあるんですよ
心は硬くするようにと
だからすごいつまらない
もう単純な英語の文章を書く
もう宿題に出しても 確実に日本語訳は下にあるんです
例えば動詞入れ替えてくださいとかね
なんとかとか もう空きがあって
まあ一応一つ選んで 下にはちゃんと訳がついているんです
そうすると日本語から決して頭は脱出しないんです
そこで固めてもらうんです
ということは 教育者はあなた方をくたこといじめますけど
能力だけは与えてあげませんという
ようすごい親切な態度で成長させませんよと
しかし 地獄のように苦しませますよと
勉強する場合は で そこは私はなんでそういう偏見を持っているのかというと
自分たちも英語を学ぶ
学んだんですから そういう訳は入らなかったんですね
初めからあの 知らない単語とか何とかあったら
自分たちで辞書を引いて調べるんですけど
ちょこちょこっとできるようになってくると
単語の説明も全部英語でやるんですね
だから国の文字一つも質問状とかありますから
入ってこないんです だからまあ英語の授業になってくると
もう頭はその世界に入れ替えないと
私は同時にドイツ語もフランス語も昔学んでみたことがありますけど
やっぱりもう最初の授業からもう他の言語は入りませんね
最初の授業は あら これ困ったもんだとかね
おっかないと思ったんですけど
もうなんのことない  2番目からなんのことない
スムーズに行くんですね
そこで心入れ替わるとすごい自動的になるんです
全然気付くもなんともないんです
そこでフランス語を一緒に勉強する友達の顔を見ただけでも
頭全部フランスになって
もうフランス語でしゃべる
ドイツ語の仲間を見ただけでも
見ただけでも 頭の中ドイツ語が絡んでくるんですね
それでもう誰がいたってもドイツ語を喋ったりするし
それで英語と喋れないけど
わからない人が来てくると
英語が出てくるし 国の言葉を喋らないといけない人に見ると
国の言葉が出てくるし
自分では努力もなんともしてないんです
ただ自動的に頭の中を入れ替え
繰り返す スイッチ入れ替えてくれるんですね
それで日本に来たらさっぱり全部忘れちゃったんです
日本語入れると全部硬くなっちゃって
だから日本語勉強する人は一番最後にもうもう死ぬ瞬間になってから学んだ方がいいんですって思うんですけど
でなきゃこれから学ぶのは全部できなくなるんだから
まあとにかく何か学ぶと頭は硬くなるっていうことはまあ確実にあります
そうでない人間はいますけど
我々はそういう人々はすごい知識人でけた違いの頭の人やとかね
天才やとかね そういうふうに扱ったりします
特に文学芸の人文系の勉強は一人前になって世界的に名前を上げる場合は
かなり柔軟的な心を持ってないとできないんです
すごい難しいんです 科学はもう誰にでもできます
もう決まって固めちゃいますから
頭をね あるいくつかの概念に
しかし 科学者の中でも世界的ですごい立場ある人々はそうじゃない
柔軟性を持ってるんです
それで何でも知りたがる
やりたがるというのは
まあこれは柔軟 優柔不断の一種ですよ
ただ単にあれもやりたい
これもやりたいだけではうまくいくわけじゃないんです
そういうことをやりませんだからね
そういうことで この我々の心が無限に能力はあるんだけど
ものすごい概念というゴミを入れて入れて入れて
もう何にもならない もう硬いものにしているんです
じゃあ前のもうちょっと喋りますけど
あの そういうことで心は硬いんだから
何かに挑戦するということは今はできないんだから
目的をそこで挑戦するでしょうに
だから目的に達したっていうことは
それなりの心の成長が必要なんです
だから心の成長を無視して目的に達するということは成り立たないんです
東大に入りたいと目的を設定したら
心はそのままでということは成り立たないんです
それなりの心を変えないと
そこはまあ東大入学っていうのはある一定ワンパターンのものだから
それで心は固まりますけど
硬くなるんだけど それでもその形に自分の心を入れ替えなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それには柔軟性が必要になっちゃうんです
だから目的に達するということは
ある程度で心の形を変えて心を伸ばすということでもあります
硬い心は伸ばせないんですね
そういうことで 6番目に行きます
無知が自分を支配する
これはあんまり説明しなくてもあまりいいと思いますけど
無知っていうのは反対は理性なんですね
我々は理性で生きるということはまずしないんです
気分で感情で生きているんだからね
これが無知ですよ ですから
まあうまくいかないんですね
無知な人に有意義な目的を作ることはできません
目的に達する方法も理解できません
無知ですからね ただ好きと思うだけで
挑戦してはいけないことにも挑戦する場合もあります
やってはいけないことも
無知な人はやってみるんですね
あの よく流行ってましたけど
外国ではね あの 何でしたっけ
あれは 大麻ですかね グラスと英語で普通の俗語で言いますけどね
あの 何かそれ吸ったら頭がしっかりするんだと
それで勉強勉強はできるようになるんだと
大学生やらもう一生懸命その葉巻を作って吸ったり吸ったりするというね
だからそれはやってはいけないことなんですけど
無知だから 楽に勉強したいんだから
楽に他のことを忘れて勉強に集中したいという目的で
そういう麻薬を使ったりはする場合もあります
そういう風にやってはいけないことまで無知な人はやるんです
目的の妨げになることも勘違いして行うこともある
なんとなくする努力なので
成功には達しません だから無知な人は努力しても
なんとなくやってみるというね
無知ということなんですね
やってみるかという感じで
そうすると成功には達しません
初めにお釈迦様の言葉がありましたからね
そんな甘いものじゃないんで
人生は 目的を決めたら
もうものすごいしつこく
その目的に達するまで精進しなくちゃいけないんです
はい それでだいたいはワンセクション終わったと終わります
それは以上 捨捨する原因
まあ時間どれぐらい行ったかわからない
え？ 今分です  うん では続けて次のセクションやります
次のセクションはちょっとこれよりは長いんです
途中で止めることはちょっとできないんです
そういうわけで ここでちょこっと休みを入れて
次をさーっと勢いでやります
はい